hey motion designers today we're going
to talk about how to transform any
visual with grunge overlays and effects
let's get started
[Music]
hey motion designers my name is Cameron
with motion science and as I said today
we're talking about how to transform any
visual into a much more tactile and
organic looking visual by using grunge
overlays and some simple effects and I
can't wait to show you what I'm talking
about but before we dive in I want to
tell you very quickly I have a free gift
for you over at motionscience.tv guide
it's my complete guide to mastering
organic motion design with After Effects
and it is a guide full of tips tricks
and techniques that will transform your
digital looking renders into organic
tactile renders like you see in my work
a lot of times I see motion designers
spit out renders from After Effects and
they just look very digital but with
these techniques I'm going to teach you
in this guide you're going to create
more organic looking motion design just
go to motionscience.tv guide download
the PDF it's absolutely free you will
not regret it okay so let's jump into
how to create better visuals by adding
some simple grunge overlays and effects
let's jump into after effects all right
to start things off I've got this visual
render here and this is something I
downloaded off of artgrid.io it's some
stock footage it looks pretty
interesting to begin with it's like this
kind of dreamy nebula with some really
interesting colors but we can make it
way more interesting
way more in the motion science Style by
the steps I'm going to show you here so
let's start by
going to effect and we're going to go up
to color correction Hue and saturation
and the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to drop the master saturation
by about 30. and the reason I'm doing
this is because typically with grunge
type Aesthetics
for the most part you don't see really
saturated visuals at least I don't
doesn't mean you can't have saturated
visuals but for this example I want it a
little bit less saturated and then we're
going to type in up here under effects
and presets we're going to type in
mirror
let's find out let's double click it to
add and this is a 4K footage so let's go
ahead and Center up the the reflection
Center to 1920 by 1080
and let's go ahead and reverse
to 180 degrees so it's upside down like
that and that's looking pretty cool
already
you can see here and we could just stick
with that but let's take it a step
further let's go back to effects and
presets and type in CC collida
and we'll double click that and we're
going to change it to unfold I think
that might work let's go ahead and scale
this footage up I'm gonna go all the way
to 400 percent uh something like that
and let's move the center point here so
it's kind of offset I moved it down and
if we preview this it's already looking
kind of interesting right it's now it
does have that kind of mirror
Kaleidoscope effect which I see
sometimes but it looks pretty dope uh
right here so let's add one more effect
and this is you can add there's a lot of
different chromatic aberration effects
out there a quick chromatic aberration
too by plugging everything or actually
it's aberration three now this is a free
plug-in it's plugging everything if you
want to download it go for it I like it
but
if I'm going for my all-time favorite
I'm going to go to uh Sapphire distort
and I'm gonna go to warp chroma and here
we are and I like to use uh this
chromatic aberration subtle so I'll
click the preset for it and it's again
it's a very subtle effect so you can see
with and without very very subtle
chromatic aberration a lot of times I
see motion designers overdo it on this
side uh so that's that's all it is
pretty simple right so got that and
there's how it's looking with our
effects and it's it's like I said it's
looking pretty cool I like it I like
that part a lot right in here that's
really cool
so we're going to jump back here to
round 103 and let's add some type here
and we're going to make this like it's a
let's say it's a visual for for a
concert right for an artist that's
performing on stage we see it all the
time so I'm gonna put like a lyric up
here and I'm not gonna use that typeface
let's try this one it's kind of
interesting and I actually picked this
color ahead of time it's kind of the
pinkish color which I like a lot so
let's go ahead and drop this down in
size
move it over in here and we're going to
open up the text here and we're going to
click here on Source text and we'll move
down about four frames
and I found that I also liked this
type of face a lot that's really cool
and we'll move down further and we're
going to use this
Suicide Squad
font and then we'll go two frames
forward and we'll go back to the stamp
our font typeface
I'm gonna hit option bracket and option
in bracket so that the type just kind of
sits here
you know just like this so you can see
all right it's pretty basic at this
point we'll go ahead and hit in here so
we can just preview this section in here
and let's make this a lot bigger
maybe something like that and then we're
gonna hit P for position and we're going
to alter option click uh and do a wiggle
expression to make this wiggle around so
wiggle parentheses
let's do six three hundred
let's just see what this looks like
and let's make a little bit more Steppy
right it's like way too smooth so let's
go to effect and we'll go down to time
and we'll go to posterize time
and let's turn this down
and now it's a lot steppier it's looking
pretty cool now it's way too crystal
clear so we're gonna go up here and add
some blur to the type
and we'll just add like a three pixel
blur like so
and let's add some displacement mapping
as well effect distort and displacement
map and we'll come back to this one
because we're going to have some of the
the grunge textures affect this and make
it look a little bit more interesting so
we'll definitely come back uh to the
displacement map but for now
this is how it looks and let's duplicate
this and take it further down the
timeline and then we'll duplicate it
again and bring it here in the middle
and let's just change this to
because we did set keyframes we need to
update each keyframe here so remember us
uh let's say who we
were
we'll go here
who we were
and this is a little bit tedious here
but who we were
and then
we're good now yeah
and I also want to increase the size so
let's go ahead and hit as for scale
I just want this type to be a lot bigger
so same here we'll go scale we'll scale
this up
and we'll go down here to the end and
we'll also scale this one up
and let's also kind of offset the
position maybe bring it up here
and for this one and we'll just hit P
for position and we'll
maybe drag it over here
up in here so then if I preview this
it's not super important I can read
everything
because it remember again like this is a
tour visual so it's up on screen it's
probably a super popular song that
people already know the lyrics for and
this is like maybe the song title or
something like that so that works for me
okay so let's start bringing in some
interesting textures here so I'm going
to go into my assets and I've got a lot
of footage here this is just because I
was playing around with different ideas
uh you know it never comes just
immediately when I'm working on this
stuff there's usually some some trial
and error and things like that we're
going to go with composite 14.
right here again this is from the motion
science texture pack if you haven't
checked them out definitely do they're
really awesome
so the first thing I'm going to do here
is I'm going to go to effect Channel
invert
so we've got black type on white and
we're going to change the mode to
something like a soft light just like
that
looking pretty cool and we're going to
scale this up to 300 percent again
looking super pixelated but that's you
know part of the aesthetic I'm going for
here
and we're going to go to effect color
correction CC toner which is a great
coloring effect that I like to use a lot
and keep it on tritone and I found that
I really like this kind of purple color
here
and it just kind of really Blends in or
Works nicely with the background footage
we already have so you can see how this
is really starting to come together now
so what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to hit command D to duplicate this and
we're going to replace this composite
with a background which background 33 I
found that I really liked
and we're going to set this to Overlay
and we're going to scale it down Smalls
maybe something like 65
and this one this is you know how it's
looking right so if we play this back
it's pretty interesting
but what I'm seeing right off the top is
like these the textures in here are way
too crisp for me so I'm going to go to
effect and we're going to go to blur and
sharpen and we're going to do fast box
blur
maybe like a four yeah it might be too
much maybe a three then we're gonna go
to effect blur and sharpen
uh directional blur
and let's actually turn up this one and
then let's also increase this one a lot
yeah so now it's you know it's just got
this it's there it's a little you know
hazier
for lack of a better term uh just softer
it's a really nice grunge texture and I
duplicated it because I want to use the
same inverts and the same CC toner
effects we've got that there
and then we're going to duplicate this
background and we're gonna go to
background 18 which I found I really
liked
and for this we're going to turn off
directional blur
and fast box blur
we're also going to scale this one down
to about 51. so this just adds some
grittiness over the top of everything
right these kind of speckled grit
textures
which look really nice and let's go
ahead and preview this and see how it
looks and there's our preview
and it's looking pretty cool right it's
like completely changed the visual the
original visual now one thing I want to
do is I want to go back to remember how
we had a displacement map we added here
I want to go back to that displacement
map and I want to set it to composite
14.
and 50 seems to work just nice we'll
change this one to composite 14 as well
so you can see it just really grunges up
that type
and let's go back to this one change it
to composite 14 as well and I think I'm
this one I might drop the position down
a little bit
maybe even the scale
something like that
and if we preview that now remember this
is half res again
um but just adding that displacement map
to that type uh really made it even much
more interesting as well and at this
point I could call it good because I do
like what I'm seeing here this would be
an awesome like tour visual uh up on
stage you know behind a band or
something like that'd be really cool but
we could take it even one step further
and use my favorite plug-in right now
which I talked about in a previous video
and that's from dehancer
um and I absolutely love it so let's go
here to layer new adjustment layer and
we'll call this
effects
and we're gonna go down to effects film
emulation decancer Pro and a lot of
times what happens is if I find a really
awesome plug-in I will use it a lot for
a while because it just kind of blows my
mind and that's what this plugin has
done so
I'm going to go to the film and I'm just
going to change just a couple things
here we're going to go down to
I found out I really liked this one a
lot and I'm just going to go to halation
enable that
and go to bloom and enable that
and that's literally all I'm going to do
I'm going to change this to full res
and let's preview it and see how it
looks so there we go we went from this
to this
by just adding some simple grunge
overlays some very simple effects in
After Effects and that is proof that you
can take any Visual and really expand on
it and and make it look better and
that's what I love to do I love to to
take a simple Visual and add an organic
and tactile feel to it and make it look
even cooler in the motion science style
and that's exactly what you get if you
go download my free pdf guide over at
motionscience.tv guide It's chock full
of tips tricks and techniques just like
this to help your motion design look
more tactile more organic so definitely
go check it out it's my free gift to you
as always thank you for watching this
video and I'll see you in the next one
thank you
[Music]